how long does it take to get your big
break I got a question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys David who
wrote in to say Evan how long did it
take you to get your big breakthrough in
business how long have you been at it
this is a great question and a lot of
entrepreneurs have a notion that it
takes a certain amount of time takes
five years it takes ten years before you
become successful for me I've had my
business this business for it's a good
question maybe 12 years now 12 years but
my big breakthrough out you came with my
first company and I had a software
company and was struggling to get by
making 300 bucks a month barely
surviving and got to the point where I
said I quit this is not working I'm not
making money I'm losing self-confidence
I don't feel like like I'm getting paid
what I'm worth I'm working for less than
minimum wage here you know I've been
I've been putting time and it's not
working out so what I'm gonna do and it
went like that for about a year spent a
good year working on this business and
it wasn't working out and my big
breakthrough came at about the year mark
where I realized that I'm not the first
guy to try to sell software before and I
started modeling success and I looked at
guys like bill gates of microsoft they
looked at mcafee i looked at intuit i
look at how they got started how they
made their first meeting because that's
what i was trying to do because i was
trying to come up with all these ideas
myself and it just wasn't working out
for whatever reason all the ideas I had
were not working and it wasn't for a
lack of effort and it wasn't for a lack
of trying and wasn't for a lack of
wanting this business to do well it just
wasn't working and once I made that
change so there's one part of Microsoft
strategy that worked really well that I
wanted to apply and was partnerships and
it's basically find people who are
already selling to your target market
and find a way to partner up with them I
said you know what it's worth trying
I've tried everything else nothing else
is working so let's give it a shot and
see what happens and within a month I
had my first deal and I started reaching
out the people who already were selling
to my market they were selling other
software to mark
target market and I partnered up with
them and I convinced one company to pay
me 13 and a half thousand dollars up
front to be our distributor to be our
partner here and I was I was I was
overwhelmed like 13 and a half thousand
dollars are you kidding me 13 a half
thousand dollars that's so much money
that's crazy and and looking back now
you might think of a 13 k man Evan come
on that's nothing what are you doing I
was making 300 bucks a month man 13 and
a half thousand dollars that's that's
good money that that that gave me
confidence like somebody actually
believes in this thing like this could
actually take off and so that one deal
that one deal maybe wasn't a huge huge
huge never evaluated but it created the
breakthrough moment for me because it
was easy to replicate so I could do that
deal and then do another one like it and
another one like it and another one like
it and pretty soon had a business that
was making some serious money and I got
acquired and so that one moment became
my breakthrough moments it happened
about a year after i joined the business
and became an owner and came basically
after so much frustration that that I
almost quit and when you're at that
point you're willing to try anything at
least I was because I wanted to save
this business I wanted to make it work
out and so it took me about a year it
doesn't have to take you that long or
may take you longer there's no rule at
least in my book that says you have to
be around for X number of years before
it takes off but really it was at that
point where I was at my lowest low that
I discovered that you know what a half I
have to try something else because
what's what what I'm doing right now
it's not working at Mon success was the
answer for me so try it out for yourself
find someone who's already done what
you're trying to do look at how they did
it look at how they went from the idea
to making their first million not how
they make an extra million dollars now
it doesn't matter 0 to 1 how did it go 0
to 1 look at those strategies in the
pipe into your business and hopefully
you'll see similar growth belief for
those
watching like the video thumbs up below
leave a comment ask the question to make
a video response and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much i'll see you soon